he's a great Kinnear the new house at
cards cast member along with Diane Lane
and the final season of house of cards
but he's been in so many other movies as
good as it gets you got mail Little Miss
Sunshine uh you were nominated as good
as it gets Best Supporting Actor is that
right I won oh you won no I didn't but I
wasn't at all well that would have been
I mean I would have bought what would
you did you have a speech did you ever
give this speech okay you want to give
this speech now if you would want and
hold on here let's just get that up
let's get it over with
Thanks and the winner is Greg Kinnear
Greg Kinnear thanks great to be here
honored to be nominated and to finally
pull it pull it home thank you who beat
you Robin Williams for Good Will Hunting
oh so I had no issues with that he was
unbelievable and it was a great group it
was like Anthony Hopkins Burt Reynolds
was in the category and for good Boogie
Nights okay yeah so it was a fun night
took my parents what is that moment like
when they've announced everybody and
there's that little pause and there's a
camera on you and then what do you think
yeah the guy comes down you know and he
basically takes a knee right here with
the camera so you're like you tried act
like you don't see it but it's it's
literally you can feel the heat from the
lens pointing at you and you just I I
don't know fortunately Best Supporting
Actor happens very quickly so it's the
in fact it's the first thing so the
shows started
I've finally was there and I would say
about 48 seconds after Billy Crystal had
done his opening it was over I'd lost
and then you got to sit there the entire
time and you got to sit there the entire
time but but it was a good show and I it
was a thorough pleasure to be there it
was incredible but Nicholson was up for
yeah best best act yes he did yeah he he
unlike me I see where you're going
yeah he did I think I'm skewing negative
and
I don't mean to I'm better than it was
he did win as did did Helen and and we
got yeah the show the movie did really
well it's a great film and still pops up
every now and then out there Andy okay
but was that your first big big break is
with movies it well I had done a year
two before I had done Sabrina which was
a Sydney [ __ ] he'd cast me and
Sabrina off of talks soup that's a brave
man and you know I did that film that
was really the first you know big movie
that I ever did okay what do they see
cuz talk soup you did something that was
unique yeah we're taking clips from TV
shows and you were having fun yeah and
so what do you think they saw where or
did Nicholson want you or how does that
work that where you get this role in
this big movie well in it Sabrina I
think it's Sydney was from a very small
town in Indiana smaller than the town I
was from originally I'm from Logansport
and he was from even I think a Lafayette
and he had seen me on the television and
said who is this guy he had auditioned
everybody in the planet for the role and
he just was like when he found out I was
from you know I think down the road he
was just curious to meet me and and that
kind of led to an audition and got me
the job the as good as it gets was just
Jim Brooks you know was an incredible
director and and writer and talent and
he had a wonderful project that that he
he sent to me and I went in and again it
was a I did go to Jack's house and have
to read with him which was terrifying
but wait you go to Nicholson's house on
Mulholland that's right yeah yeah you
walk in you see all that great artwork
there yeah it's yeah it's uh
I mean it's slightly terrifying you try
to act like you're not nervous to be
there I mean you try to act like being
at Jack's house is a and I
run-of-the-mill kind of the only other
time you've been have you been there
since no oh yes I have been back a
couple of times
yeah I've been back yeah I've been
invited back sure okay we've gone to a
couple games together and for a while we
actually played a lot of golf Jack and I
did well you're good Jack's not good
right I think yeah yeah yeah I
can I take the fifth on that when you
set it up you can nod like I'm trying to
be positive with you now I I don't I
don't think he was he was not
particularly good but I'm not
particularly good either I mean you know
he's an amateur he was an amateur golfer
I don't think he's playing a lot much
anymore but I still belong to bel-air
yes yeah do CL Michaels there I do see
how yes I play I play with Alan on you
know a semi-regular basis depends how
the seasons go on where he is where I am
most famous person you play golf with
aside from Nichols it was Nicholson man
just like a president of you I've never
played with Tiger never played with a
president almost played with Clinton one
time but that didn't pan out and no I
guess you didn't win the Academy war
probably that when when you see the
script for a little miss sunshine yeah
because it's such a sneaky great movie
yes and Alan Arkin is brilliant in there
and I mean just the whole cast yeah and
so when you see that movie
like what are you thinking that here's
grandpa teaching you know your daughter
basically striptease to win a talent
show yeah yeah you know I I actually
read that script I know you have
daughters I do I have three daughters I
I read the script and I I thought it was
good John and and Val Jonathan Dayton
Valerie Faris and the directors and they
had this girl Abigail Breslin who they
wanted to play as olive and they were
desperately trying to make this movie
because she kept getting older and so it
took him a couple of years so she went
from like seven to nine and then finally
I think one of the producers just wrote
the check to make the film but I read
the script the first time a friend of
Mines a producer sent it to me and I
thought yeah this is good this is good
is it happening with me you know but but
I didn't follow out of my chair I I
really didn't it's a testament to my
lack of good insights because I really
missed it the first time I read it and
then once it became a reality and it
looked like it was coalescing I
look at it obviously again and I was
like this is unlisted so rich every
character is great every moment is great
and and in fact they saw paul dano at
The Tonight Show last night we were kind
of rehashing our Little Miss Sunshine
rehearsal stories because we spent like
a week together where we had that little
yellow bus and and we all would drive
around the cast all of us Alun efforts
in the back and we just buzz around Los
Angeles and I don't know we went bowling
one afternoon we'd do silly actor things
but it was very cool yeah a lot of fun
we were also curious about you you
played Dick Vermeil yeah but were you
around
dick what research do you do when you're
portraying Dick Vermeil I went up to he
was in his last year at Kansas City
right and I went up to his training camp
I think was at Appleton Wisconsin does
anybody would that be right what is it
that sounds right I think that's where
they used to practice yeah and the
Packers will check yeah
we're just making stuff up yeah exactly
anyway wherever it was I think it was I
know it was Wisconsin I went up to the
training camp and and they you know hot
summer watching these guys work he was
he was accessible you know he was super
nice and I remember him like taking me
you know with all the guys at one point
you know I'm playing dick it's gonna be
it's a it's a good script a good project
I didn't really know his work you know I
knew him as a coach but I didn't know
him that well so was a really great
learning experience kind of get to tap
into the guy and all of a sudden is we
were standing there with him coaching
the guys they're all taking a knee he's
doing his coach deal he says and now
Greg would like to say a few words
and I was like I had absolutely I
remember it was like one of the great I
mean just sweat pouring down my face
going football is important the number
of reasons because the movies invincible
so this is 1996 yeah so yeah a couple of
decades ago yeah yeah
yes McLovin what oh it's River Falls
just so we're clear Oh River Falls
Wisconsin Scott oh yeah by the way a
life long and Dick Vermeil and I cried
every time he cried and you did a great
job I just want to say I was at
Westchester training camp as a kid
watching the Eagles like you did in the
movie yeah and you nailed it look I was
so taken with you there's people who are
cynical we're always kind of cynical
about his his emotion and thinking yeah
this is whoa this guy can't control it
or that it's there's some sort of
artifice to it
i watch tape on him and it's all over
youtube there you can go research it
yourself he honestly had just such a
heart I mean he really did was just such
a passionate guy and it just really came
out so it's great fun to play him
because I felt like he was different you
know he really was different let me give
the a full introduction house of cards
and a Greg Kinnear and Diane Lane are
two new cast members here so the sixth
and final season house of cards on
Netflix premieres November 2nd I'm
curious of when you walk on have you
ever been coming into something that's
already established and firmly
established as house of cards and then
kind of figuring out what's the water
level or what's the temperature of do I
gotta get up to a certain level or am I
so it's an odd feeling with what
happened with Kevin Spacey so how do you
sort of find your way navigate well I
haven't really the answer question no I
hadn't had that experience before I mean
I did an episode of you know Modern
Family I did a thing with Ross who we
just saw stealing things on friends
years ago so I had come into and it just
for a you know bit or whatever that this
was a a an extremely well established
show and kind of an iconic show people
have very strong opinions about it so it
was
little you know off-putting coming into
it and and yeah obviously given our
speed bump that we hit right out of the
gate I Diane and I are brother and
sister billing in that Shepherd there to
basically wreak havoc against Claire
who's now the president yeah Claire well
yeah you know and so we we were up there
in we were in Baltimore and I just for
like a day or two and kind of got
getting started and and I was actually
shooting a movie in Memphis and I went
finished the work went back to Memphis
and I got a text from Diane saying are
we doing this show is this gonna happen
I was like am I already fired I didn't
know what the hell she was talking about
and then the you know Google sphere blew
up and the text started coming in and
the whole thing with with him you know
kind of you know happened they had to
shut down for you know quite a while
obviously net fix took care of the crew
which I thought was remarkable how many
shot we had just started on the first
one just a couple of days ya know it was
odd and and and then going back to it
you would think listen there's the
elephant in the room right how awkward
is this gonna be I'm the new guy plus
you have this thing that's happened but
I have to say I genuinely feel like the
the crew and and much credit I've said
to Rob and who you know there was an
easy out for her you know your co-star
this happens it's like I think maybe
this was the you know destiny we should
all walk away from this kept that train
on the tracks everybody was there they
were enthusiastic they weren't afraid to
talk about their own experiences over
the years you know but everybody knew
what the job was it's it's a big show
and and it does feel a little strange
watching this thing that I had seen for
many years I'm suddenly in the white
house with the characters that I've
known all these years and but it was
really cool it's great fun they write
devious characters do you like being a
bad guy I did in this it was great they
had a good guy because you don't you
don't have a bad guy look yeah I mean
you're a nice guy you're from the
Midwest I mean we're we're nice corn-fed
good looks I mean that's oh so it's nice
fellas
that's what we are I had to double down
on the acting you did yes they had a
double double it up no I mean honestly I
don't get that role that often so it was
yeah I mean would you like to play a
Merton like a killer like a like a total
just badass I you know I never did do
like a lot of action pictures I've been
kind of I wish I had had a gun in my
hand at some point you know for one of
the you know a think you can do like
Bruce Willis stuff you don't think it's
too late no you can tell me look at Liam
Neeson that's true that's true
yeah actually maybe it was everybody
yeah man he wasn't always killing
everybody either it still just in the
last he's had like a resurgence in the
last five seven years he's a snow plow
driver taking revenge on people in his
his new movie do you like those films
I'm not a bit you know on snow plow
genre movies yeah like he's one of the
best ones I've seen
Fritzie Fritzie does a Liam Neeson
impersonation I will hunt you down I
will find you and I will kill you okay
paulie's got a question for you who eats
get one well McLovin had his well wasn't
really a question I think he just was
fawning all over Dick Vermeil okay
there's a great movie you were in called
Green Zone Matt Damon it's a war movie
West weapons of mass destruction you
play like a steep department guy who's
really mean-spirited a bad guy how do
you know you're nailing a bad guy role
cuz I thought you were great that role
thank you
I guess I have done this I guess I'm out
of the corn Fred a nice guy a thing
apparently yeah because I forgot about
the Green Zone you know I don't know I
mean like I don't know you have to be I
remember Paul Greengrass who directed
that he's a very funny guy you know
British lovely guy great director and he
just kept saying I'm all butch you know
buh-buh butchered up just kind of more
bad and but I have more bloodshed that
was the term but it was a but but I you
know it's always in the writing it's
always in the script you know anything
ever look for any particular kind of
role I always feel like the role finds
you you read something and you're like
wow I never saw the world quite like
that or I never saw a character quite
like that and you dive in well it's you
know how you understand that because
obviously tell me about your film work
um how many movies have I been in poli
movies are films oh that's right as we
have both I don't know if I've been in a
film uh it's been pretty close but
you've been in about I'd say 18 movies
yeah Wow yeah that's quite a bit of
cinema okay here is my question for you
Greg Kinnear when I die and then they
have in memoriam at the Academy Awards
will I get my picture up there you're
going to when you die but I will I who I
have a team didn't you ask Will Ferrell
to sing at your yes I did yeah you asked
yet will to get your you got out you're
trying to get all your already stacking
the deck for the night I'm already
planning my pallbearers what would
happen what's what's the question so
there would I be up there in memoriam oh
if after 30 movies let's say 25 mmm yeah
I think you probably would I think
there's a possibilities that that
doesn't matter
listen I'm gonna lobby for it how about
that okay I gotta shake that yeah and
you don't want I'm gonna invite you to
my funeral listen it's a weird thing
Thank You Stan have you been invited to
a funeral I've been invited to a lot so
this is good I'll take anything I can
get I'll see you there I was gonna have
just Academy Award winners there yeah
open the party up a little bit for
crying out loud would you do action
elitist
would you do a one-off talk soup again I
would methey right circumstances maybes
like this is current culture yeah you
bring your smarmy snark there and just
kill it there is no shortage just good
absolutely yes see yeah I was just
checking your IMDB and I have as an
actor I have 28 credits
mmm wait credits you got it no that's
not all movies necessarily but 28
credits as an actor I'm sort of the
American Michael Caine my god yeah I you
know because you don't see you see me
you don't seem this like that you have
this aura of such a filmography I become
the role yeah right
yeah like it finds me right that's what
the great ones say Wow but you and
Daniel day-lewis man I learned a god I
did play Lincoln okay movie okay yeah
there you go
I think that's why I can't that's right
I couldn't quite put it together I I do
think and by the way my given name is
Daniel day Patrick yeah I do believe
that Daniel day-lewis retired from
acting when he saw me play Lincoln I
think that that was it he he'd said I
there's nothing I can do with the craft
here not anymore I quit
yes like yeah yes Fritzi your question
for Greg Kinnear he's got a lead I know
real quick being the son of a US
diplomat moving all around the world
Lebanon Greece eclipta how did that how
do you tap into that and how does that
made you like who you are especially as
an actor
hard to say I you know it was a great
gift you know my father took us to
faraway places but through the American
Embassy when I I was a kid and
incredible experience I mean I was
consider myself very lucky to have done
that gave me you know great perspective
on things I don't know you know in terms
of in terms of how its informal
it's just serious quite what was the
question you said this morning you were
gonna ask yes Oh what about it
grape-nuts no well you would you like
the manager of the Yankee team that went
up against the Bad News Bears
that's right bad news ray Bullock yeah I
was ray Bullock okay you were gonna ask
him that question I was gonna ask that
but then I was thinking about that maybe
be more profound listen we were into a
serious conversation there Dan if you
don't mind my bad my bad
okay fritzy what do you want to ask you
yeah did you like gotta leave
did you study any managers or coaches or
do anything baseball wise preparing for
that role is being you know the evil
manager of the other side you can just
say no I spent some time in Lebanon
which you can see Greg Kinnear in house
of cards the sixth and final season it's
Netflix premieres November 2nd thanks
for stopping by Dan thank you for having
me and I look forward to your next film
and I'll be closely it's a movie you
know cinema do you know that I at the
box office yeah two billion dollars yeah
I am box-office gold Sandler had a
little bit to do with it but the movies
I've been in two billion dollars
I'm the Will Smith of sports announcers
listen I gotta go he's got to get out of
here
thank you for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]